I usually think of things too late. In
order for you to be quick, in order for
you to be humorous, in order for you to
be creative in the moment, the most
important thing I would say here is
mastery over the foundations. And what
are the foundations? Well, you have your
vocal foundations, which are made up of
rate of speech, volume, melody,
tonality, and the pause. And then you
have your body language foundations.
This is your hand gestures, posture, eye
contact, facial expressions, and
movement. Because if you're busy in the
moment thinking about how to use your
hand gestures, how to use your voice,
what to do with your facial expressions
to be humorous, if you're busy thinking
about the skill, well, then you're not
going to be able to be quick in the
moment.
And if you relate it to the example of
car driving a car, imagine you're
driving a car, there are some people who
are good drivers, and when they're good
drivers, it means they have mastery over
the foundation. So, when they're
driving, and then a driver in front of
them does something
random and sporadic, they're able to
dodge that person. Now, if you inspect
the person who crashes versus the person
who's able to quickly dodge, well, the
first foundational thing is the person
who was able to dodge, they had more
skill.
They had better mastery over the
foundations.
So, [snorts] let's just use that as the
metaphor as we're diving into this. So,
if you master this, you're going to now
have skill and mastery over the
foundations, allowing you to dodge,
allowing you to be quick, allowing you
to be humorous in the moments you want
to be humorous in. The second thing here
is you want to be able to feel the
following. You want to feel calm,
you want to feel comfortable, and you
also want to feel clear.
And I mean that by clear-minded.
And the only way you're going to feel
those things, the only way you're going
to be in a state where you're clear,
comfortable, and calm
is if you have mastery over the
foundations.
And that's one of the wonderful benefits
that once I already know I have these
skills, I know what to do with these
things, I know how to manipulate my
voice, these things become second nature
to me. Now I'm in a place where I'm
actually more present. And the reason
I'm present is because I'm not up in my
head. Whereas think about what most
people are thinking about while they're
speaking up on stage, speaking in a
meeting. Are they present or are they in
their heads? Often they're in their
heads.
I mean, [snorts] often they're not even
thinking about the delivery mechanism.
Often they're thinking about, "Oh my
goodness, I hope everybody likes what
I'm going to say. Oh my goodness, I hope
I'm structuring what I'm saying right.
Oh my goodness, I hope that I'm not
coming across being rude. I hope they
like my idea. I hope they don't ask me a
question that I don't know the answer
to."
So when you are that much in your head,
you are not present. When you're not
present, well then now you've got no
chance of being able to pick up on
something that somebody else said and
then very quickly in that moment
deciding to move into a humorous moment
to lighten the mood.
You're not able to do that.
You have no chance. And as you master
the foundations, you'll start to find
yourself feeling more calm, more
comfortable, and you'll be more
clear-minded. And on top of that, you'll
be present. The other thing I'll bring
your attention to, the final thing is
the art of reviewing
and reflecting.
The art of reviewing and reflecting. And
this is an art form because often what
happens is when people do something
wrong,
they often don't review and reflect on
how they could have done it better.
This is actually a skill and a habit
that you must form. Now as an
entrepreneur, as a content creator, as
someone who's been in the business world
for quite a long time,
this is one of the key reasons why I
believe I'm successful. So it's a habit
that I've already built. But But for
most who don't go down the path of
entrepreneurship and go down that path
seriously, they don't develop that
habit, that second nature. Whereas I've
got that second nature, right? So if
you're new to this,
you've got to develop this. And And And
it goes all the way back down to high
school, and I remember this.
In high school, there were kids who when
they do a test and they fail, the moment
they get the test back and they failed,
they don't even look through their test.
And then there were kids who when they
get their test and they failed, they
would look through the test and work out
why they failed so they don't fail
moving forward into the future.
I was one of the kids who never looked
back at my test. That's why I kept
failing in school. And then I thought to
myself, oh, I'm just dumb.
It wasn't that I was dumb. It was that
nobody encouraged me in the classroom,
including the teacher, to look back
through my old tests and look at why I
actually failed. So they just hand out
the test and they go, all right,
everyone, onto the next topic.
We never got taught the art of
reflecting and reviewing on the outcomes
we've achieved in our lives.
It's again one of the reasons why I
believe I've been able to find more
happiness in my life because at the end
of every year, I review and I reflect
upon how I went with my life in the past
12 months. I call this process
recalibrate.
So I always recalibrate. What did I do
that I liked? What did I do that I
didn't like? What happened that made me
feel sad? I look upon I I look among all
of these things and I'm I'm looking for
patterns and clues as to what I should
be doing more of in 2026 and less of in
2026. So again, it's the art of
reviewing and reflecting. So to really
link this into what you're saying now,
you know, then I always think of things
too late. That's all right.
What you want to do is if you have a
meeting with
three of your team members and then
through that meeting, you clearly missed
out on some opportunities,
I wouldn't review and reflect 3 days
later. I would review and reflect right
after that meeting. I'd create just a 5
to 10 minute time slot and I would just
sit down and think, what could I have
done better?
Ah, I could have done this better. I
could have done that better. And the
more you do that, the more you review
and you reflect, you then start to get
to a point where
I'll draw this for you so so it makes
more sense to. So in the beginning, as
you're starting out with the skill,
okay? So think of a timeline scale. This
is the scale of time, okay? This is from
the point you do the meeting
and this is just time moving forward
into the future, okay?
So what happens is in the beginning of
your journey, you're [snorts] going to
have the meeting right here.
And then
1 hour later
you review and you reflect. So, review
and reflect.
And then you think to yourself Oh, I
just got the idea here. Damn it, why
didn't I think of this idea here? And
you'll start to beat yourself up and you
go, "Ah, damn it, why didn't I?" But as
you build the skill, as you build the
ability to review and reflect and you do
it more and more and more and more and
more
soon enough what starts to happen is
while you're in the meeting, in the
moment, you start to think of the things
that you used to think of here.
Right? But now you're going to start to
think of the actual things to say, the
humorous things to say in the present in
the meeting. That's the power of
building the skill. Whereas most people
never build the skill. So, as you start
to review and reflect 5 minutes after
experiences, 5 minutes after experiences
and you really build that habit soon,
instead of being able to think of the
ideas an hour after the meeting, 5
minutes after the meeting, in the moment
while you're talking to the person,
while they're saying words to you, you
immediately go, "Oh, there's the idea."
And then you say it.
And then you start to be able to get the
outcome you desire. But again, it's a
skill. It's a skill.
And that skill all stems again from the
foundation of you first of all mastery
over the foundations. Then after that
you'll feel more calm, more clear, more
comfortable. You'll be more present.
Then after that, you'll be able to build
the skill of reviewing and reflecting.
And these things slowly slowly but
surely help you get to the point where
you're able to do what you perceive me
to be doing, you see me doing, which is
being quick in the spot on the moment.